nearly a year after the start of talks
sudan's transitional government and the
opposition coalition
the sudanese revolutionary front are
signing a peace deal
the administration made ending conflicts
across sudan's top priority
and it's hoped this will help achieve it
we're glad that we managed to achieve a
milestone regarding achieving peace in
sudan
we know there are other factions that
are yet to sign and we hope there will
be another round to negotiate with these
groups
peace is the most important thing we
have for the transitional period
and without it all the talks about
democratic transition economic
development
is not possible so we see this as the
first step to sudan's transition
leading up to this deal agreements have
been signed by other groups that make up
the sudanese revolutionary front
each representing a different region in
sudan the groups some armed opposed the
previous government of ahmad bashir who
was overthrown in april last year
they say their regions have long been
marginalized the new deal will give a
role in the transitional government
and hand over more power to local
governments it also paves way for the
formation of a transitional legislative
assembly
the deal mediated by south sudan would
also restart sudan's 39-month
transitional period
we affirm the commitment of south sudan
and sudan's journey to peace
because sudan peace is south sudan's
peace there are still two more groups
that are yet to sign a deal
and we will continue on the issue of
peace until there is a comprehensive
peace in sudan
we don't want any more war in darfur
negotiations to end the conflict in the
western region of darfur has taken the
longest
the war there began in 2003 and has
resulted in the deaths of 300 000 people
and the displacement of 2 million the
forces of the armed groups will be
integrated into the sudanese army
reparations will be paid to those
affected by the conflict and those
displaced will be allowed to return home
we've been in these camps since 2004. we
want the conflict to end so we can go
back to our harvest into our ancestral
home
but we've not been properly consulted on
the deal that's taking place
or represented and so we're concerned it
may not hold
the deal is not the first attempt at
peace incidents conflict zones
but sudan's transitional government and
the sudanese revolutionary front
say this time there's political will to
make it last
well heber morgan is live for us now in
katsum hiber
what can you tell us about this deal i'm
thinking particularly about what the
various groups wanted versus what they
actually got
welcome the negotiations to this peace
deal that is being signed right now in
the south sudanese capital juba
took about 10 months to reach now for
the for the
transitional government to be able to
reach these deal with the various groups
that are
involved in this negotiations they had
to divide it into various tracks
that's because not all the members of
the sudanese revolutionary front which
is signing the deal
are armed and most of them had different
different grievances and different
demands
we have groups that represent the
northern and central part of the country
they were
calling or demanding for economic
representation and saying that they
wanted more shares
in the government and in the wealth that
comes out of their states that's what
they got
out of the deal now there are two areas
uh blue nile and south kordofan these
are areas that were supposed to
have a popular consultation as per a
previous peace deal that was signed in
2005.
they were supposed to decide upon south
sudan's independence whether they wanted
to be part of south sudan
or be part of sudan now that didn't
happen and resulted
in the breakout of another civil war for
sudan in 2011.
what they got out of this deal is that
they will be granted self-autonomy and
the
the wealth that comes from those two
states south kordofan and blue nile will
be shared between the government
and the local government between the
federal government and the local
government
as for the darfur groups they've been
demanding reparations and they've been
demanding
more economic development and more
wealth being shared between them
and the federal government that is
something they got as well as
their armies or their armed groups being
reintegrated
into the national army throughout the
transitional period which is set to
restart
with this deal now being signed so it
looks like most of them got most of what
they wanted the
the negotiations has been very
complicated uh it had halted several
times between the groups
and the government but it looks for now
that they say that they're set
to to start a new transitional period
and a new face and open a chapter that
is
of peace sounds like a real mammoth task
just even getting to this point
what happens next
now what happens next kim is for these
groups to come back to horton let's
remember that most of them most of these
members of the armed groups
have been out of sudan uh since uh the
war broke out in darfur
and and there were in blue nile state
and south kurdistan so many of those
members
have not seen uh the student have not
set foot in sudan for a long time
or have not seen the capital hotzoom
because as per the deal there will be a
reconfiguration of this transitional
government and the sovereign council
will be expanded as well as uh
armed groups getting representation in
the federal in in the ministries and in
the legislative assembly
we'll be seeing members of those armed
groups coming back to hartsum
but before that we will be we're
expecting to hear an announcement from
the head of the sovereign council abdel
fattah al-burhan
who is right now attending the peace
deal in juba the signing of the peace
deal in juba
we're expecting him to announce a pardon
on those
members of the armed groups because most
of them have been uh persecuted by the
government so we will be
uh we're expecting to hear an
announcement of a pardon for those
members of the armed groups to pave way
for them
to be able to come to khartoum and start
taking up positions in the sovereign
council
in the council of ministers and we'll
start seeing uh consultations between
the armed groups
and the forces of freedom and change in
terms of how this legislative assembly
uh the transition legislative assembly
which has been put on hold
for a long time will be formed okay
thank you for that heaven morgan live
for us
in khartoum